- C'est la une du quotidien
français Libération quelques
"L'urgence attendra",
peut-on lire, tandis qu'en
arrière-plan, la Terre en feu.
Un portrait certes pessimiste,
mais qui témoigne d'un bilanpep.
PAPATRICK BONIN, responsable
Climat-Énergie Greenpeace Canadé
un leader à la hauteur
de ce qu'il aurait pu faire.
de Greenpeace, y voit une
occasion manquée de la part
du gouvernement Trudeau.
- C'est définitivement honteux
de voir que le Canada a fait
pétrolière et gazière.
Au-delà des belles paroles,
il n'a pas livré concrètement
à réduire ses émissions
plus rapidement.
- Il déplore que le Canada ait,
lobbys pétroliers et gaziers,
tandis que des entreprises
pétrolières canadiennes étaient
ANDRÉANNE BRAZEAU, analyste
pol., mobilité durable Équiterre
- On voit que le gouvernement
de donner une tribune à cette
industrie-là et pour nous,
c'est d'une incohérence totale.
- L'organisme Équiterre dénonce
un double discours et ne peut
passage que Justin Trudeau
brillait par son absence
lors de ce grand rendez-vous.
- On peut pas s'attendre
à ce que le C
garant d'une responsabilité
vis-à-vis des autres pays
si la prin
politique n'est pas présente.
- Le Canada peut-il encore
jouer
sur la scène internationale?
KRISTINA MICHAUD p.-p. du Bloc
québ., changements climatiques
que le Canada s'est brûlé.
Quand tu vas à la COP27
et qu'au même moment
tu donnes des peplplplplplplplps
des zones marines protégées
à des industries, ça envoie
un message contradictoire.
(anglais)- - - - - - - - - - - s
vulnérables suscite assurément
un brin d'espoir.
- C'est malheuresement
un
des demi-avancées.
- Mais qui ne suffira pas pour
que le Canada obtienne la note
de passage, selon Patrick Bonin.
Radio-Canada, Montréa